how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
loki was a fantastic series that had
huge
implications for the mcu moving forward
mainly the multiverse and while the
finale has been out for over a week now
we're still getting little tidbits about
the show
and today we actually have some
information about two scrapped scenes
that were supposed to be
in the loki series one involving rocket
raccoon and the
other is the king loki scene that we saw
in the trailers that we never
saw in the actual series i gotta say
they did
a really good job with that scene in the
trailers actually convincing a lot of
people that
loki was going to be the main villain of
the show
not king but over here we were the kang
gang the entire time but still
it led to some confusion as to what we
were going to see in the finale
ultimately it was king i guess
technically not i guess it was really
he who remains but his variants are king
and as he said he's been called a
conqueror before but the king loki scene
is finally
explained and we have a rocket raccoon
cameo that we almost got
but didn't it and we'll talk about that
in this video and of course if you love
marvel and want to stay up to date be
sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell
so marvel studios is assembled for the
loki series has recently come out
and during the episode they showed us
some loki concept art that we had never
seen before
this concept art shows loki standing in
line in the tva
it's much different than what we saw in
the first episode where it was just him
and another person in this concept art
it's him plus
a lot of other people including rocket
raccoon and what seems to be
ravangers ravagers from guardians of the
galaxy so it looks like originally
rocket raccoon was supposed to make a
cameo in the very first episode of the
loki series however as we know this
never made it into it now as far as what
he did
well it's rocket racoon he really could
have done anything but i would
personally like to think that
in some timeline rocket finally got
bucky's arm which created a nexus event
how much for the gun not for sale okay
how much for the um
[Music]
oh i'll get that on now this cameo
really wouldn't have meant anything it
just would have been
something really cool to see on screen
much like lady siff and the loki series
kicking loki
over and over and over again in the
worst place possible
if you want to talk about mephisto and
hell i can assume that that's pretty
much what hell is and lady siff is
mephisto
i hope you know you deserve to be alone
and you always will be
all right a bad memory prison i'll
quaint
so we missed a cameo from rocket raccoon
but we also missed
another cameo from throg the frog
of thunder and this was actually going
to be in the king loki scene the footage
that we saw in the trailer where loki is
king of asgard but we never actually saw
in the series
it was ultimately deleted but we do have
a description of what it was going to be
and according to loki composer natalie
holt it was going to be this big
grand moment where loki takes over the
crown in asgard and then you see thor as
a frog
this is how natalie described it that
was a moment in episode 1 when mobius is
showing loki his life
there were more moments in there i think
they just kind of got cut down
to kind of give it a bit more focus but
there were a few extra moments in there
and that frog of thunder moment was one
of them
i had actually written i had done
something with the choir for it like it
was this big
grand moment where loki takes over the
crown and asgard and then you see thor
as a frog he was then asked if the scene
that we saw in the trailers with king
loki
raising his arms was going to be the
same scene with the frog of thunder in
it
natalie confirmed yes she said yeah
where he's like raising like this his
arms and wearing a crown
yeah that was part of it it was going to
be in it referring to the frog of
thunder so that was the scene that we
missed
loki becoming king of asgard and thor as
the frog of thunder
which could have been done by loki after
all he's turned thor into other things
before and loki has transformed himself
into many different things so maybe
that's how he finally got the throne he
turned thor into a frog after all
kid loki did manage to kill thor at one
point i'm sure there's a version of loki
that could have turned thor
into a frog even though that is
definitely not what happens in the
comics but these are two scenes that we
never saw
in the loki series what do you think
about them would you have liked to have
seen them
in the show or do you think that due to
pacing and the tone of the overall show
it was fine that they were left out
i personally am fine with both of these
scenes being left out i actually thought
in episode 1 where loki is in line at
the tva was pretty funny as it was
and we did get our throgg cameo in one
episode as well so
i'm kind of happy with that but be sure
to let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and for live updates you can
always follow me on instagram and
twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof